[Music]
hello welcome I'm Jerome do--she I'm a
software engineer at Google I'm Chris
Herrington I'm more social engineer and
I'm also a software engineer hi guys I'm
Leo I'm a product manager and so we're
here to talk about their Gradle plugin
but first I wanted to talk about Bill
speed
you've probably heard from Karen this
morning we recently looked at our data
and had some interesting findings that I
wanted to share with you today in old
transparency the metrics that are gonna
see comes from developer we opted into
sharing their data with us so if that's
your case thank you very much all right
so first we looked at Bill time change a
little bit across a couple bill times
before and right after an Android Gradle
plug-in upgrade and so what you see here
is the median improvement in speed in
percents and you can see that outside of
a minor regression in three one two
we've been pretty consistent at seven or
eight percent and even 20 percent with
three 200 so we thought okay if everyone
upgrades to the latest three two or the
latest release build speed should be
getting faster and faster right well not
exactly
turns out that when we looked at Bill
speed over time it is getting slower and
slower and I don't want to coalesce to
build speed conundrum but it got us a
little bit puzzled how is it possible
that on one end we kid we keep improving
with every release and on the other end
we keep seeing bill speed gets slower
and slower so after some exploration we
realized that the build ecosystem is
very complex and I'm a new guy and enjoy
it so I can tell you it is very complex
for me and it's rapidly evolving with so
many things that can impact your build
for example your apps are growing your
writing more code that's great
it can slow down you your bill a little
bit but that's not the lion chair turns
out that 96% of you use some form of
Gradle plugin outside of the Android
Gradle plugin whether it's another
Google plug-in or third-party plug-in or
even something that you wrote for your
own app or your own company and when we
took a look at some of those plugins
they were not all super optimized
there's also a lot of annotation process
are out there and they sometime lacked
incrementality so when you do a tiny
change it has to recompile everything
and your build speed goes away some new
languages like Java 8 for example or
Kotlin can have some impact on your
speed with Java 8 we mitigated some of
the impact by merging the dexing and the
sugaring together in one step with the
eight and working a lot with JetBrains
whim to improve the cutline compiler and
annotation processor there's also some
resource scaling issues if you have a
lot of modules some of our existing
resource pipeline is not necessarily
optimized so you can see that that's a
lot and when you add all of this it can
have a pretty significant impact on your
bill and to top it off a recent survey
that we did show that that 60% of
developer either do not analyze build
speed at all or do not know how to so
there's definitely an awareness problem
as well around what can cause delay to
your build alright so what can we do
well first I want to recognize that some
of what I just mentioned comes directly
from us Google at large and we're really
serious about improving this we're
taking step internally to improve
existing features as well as the new one
but as I mentioned there's also an
awareness problem in tooling issue and
we want to launch new features and new
attribution features that can help you
better understand what's going on with
your build and what is really impacting
your build and we'll cover this in a
little bit we're also really doubling
down on performance features working
together with Gradle and there's a lot
of new
features that'll let jerome chris and
isabella sure with you thank you alright
so let's get started what did we add in
the latest 3.2 release so the first
thing i want to talk about is
incrementality in a notation processor
that Leo alluded before as you probably
know Java C and even cotton C has been
incremental for quite some time however
if you have annotation processors all of
these incrementality goes out of the
door and so it's a big problem and so it
has enormous performance ramifications
because when we look at our internal
dashboards we can see that the JVM
bytecode production tasks are the most
consuming task of our build times so
basically being a non incremental is a
huge problem so glad all with Groupon
and with Google has come up with incap
which is aimed as making annotation
processors incremental now there's
really two level of supports that we are
aiming for the first one is called
aggregating which basically means that
if you change a class which is annotated
with an annotation of interest we will
have to recompile all the classes which
are annotated with the same annotations
so it's not exactly incremental but it's
better than we implement then
recompiling everything the other one
which is called isolating which is much
better much more fine-grained will allow
you to recompile only what has changed
right so there's this different level of
support what is important to realize for
some of you is that if you have
annotation processes yourself that you
developed in-house it would be your
responsibility to make those annotation
processors incap compliant we are
working hard internally to make the most
popular annotation processors incap
compliant so we're gonna do dagger and
we're gonna do unit data binding and all
this kind of stuff but if you have your
own you're gonna have to work on it
yourself and if you don't we also plan
to make it very very clear that if we
have to revert our compilation to not be
incremental we're going to make it very
clear which annotation processors are
making forcing us to not be incremental
so if you're providing those expect to
have some bad publicity coming from us
saying yeah we are running on
incremental
because of those annotation processors
the second thing I want to talk about is
a bundle so you must have heard about it
by now
in the past when people wanted to reduce
they pick a size they had to do multi
apk which risotto there's a lot of
manual steps related to deployments was
very complicated so now what you can do
is basically create this app bundle
which is a glorified zip file with a
universal apk in a specific format which
cannot be immediately installed on a
device but can be used by the Play Store
to pre create all these different apks
for all the different devices that
you're targeting so you've got fast
delivery all this nice feature without
having to do it yourself now one of the
thing you need to understand as a
developer using the Android kernel
plug-in is that there are things which
have changed because of that right for
instance you know you can define if you
use modality and you have feature
modules for instance you can define a
number of things inside those which are
modules yet the base module is the one
that will actually be providing some
information even for the future modules
so for instance the application ID the
version code soon the signing
information all of those comes from the
base ID in theory we would want to
reduce the dsl per module type so that
you could only you could only provide on
on the Builder girdle of each of this
feature module the exact information
that we know we will be using but we
don't have time so it's the same DSL
everywhere and you have to be aware that
some of it will be ignored in the future
modules also for instance the mapping
file for bundled file will also be for
the for the base module now when you add
module IIT inside your application it's
relatively easy at the build level all
you have to do is to use the right
plugin as I described in this slide in
the base module you have the base
functionality and then you apply the
application plug-in which you have used
for years in the future module you can
apply the dynamic feature now we have to
declare out special dependency from the
base module to all of the different
feature
and I will explain you later why this is
necessary but it is something that you
need to understand is that obviously you
have a dependency from the Future module
to the base but you also need to make a
dependency from the base to the features
so as an example here we've got the
coach ranking flow and I'm going to show
how these changes when you start
introducing feature modules and
modularity inside your application so
here you've got a simple example you've
got a base module you've got three
feature modules module a module beam and
you'll see so far nothing's too specific
of course each of these future modules
depend on the base now by adding this
DSL declaration we are declaring now the
dependency or the fact that those
feature does Muto's module a B and C are
feature modules ok so far simple but you
can see that now we have this dependency
going both ways so when we go through
the build flow the first thing that we
do obviously is that we build normally
all the Java source files we compile all
the Java source files into classes that
jar that's so normal that's the normal
process that we go through when we build
each of these different modules but the
thing that really starts to differ when
you're dealing with with future modules
is that we are publishing back all of
these Java files back to the main module
and that's absolutely necessary because
when we do the code shrinking you need
to have a global view of the application
you can't do a shrinking just on the
future module because you will not know
how and what the use of the base class
was for instance so once you have those
published to the base you can feed it to
the chancre and the splitter and
eventually it's going to create
equivalent Dex files as you can guess
there is more or less a one-to-one
mapping between the original Java file
containing the class files and the Dex
files containing the textures but it's
not exactly a one-to-one so for instance
let's say that you had classes that were
in your base module that you thought
would be shared by a different feature
but only end up being used by say module
B then it's perfectly legal for the
splitter to decide that he wants to move
those classes into
Dex beaded jaw instead of keeping them
inside the main Dexter jar of the main
module but otherwise you can more or
less image in that there is a one-to-one
mapping so once this is done you've got
all these Dex files which are still
residing in the base module now they're
going to flow back into the originating
module dynamic feature module and that
we do that so that we can have as much
parallelism in your build so as you can
see at the beginning we had the
compilation happening in each of the sim
modules it was potentially parallelized
depends on the machine you have but if
you have a powerful machine all of those
would run in parallel then we moved
everything to the base then it becomes
kind of a bottleneck for the build
system because it has to wait for all
the modules to be ready to be able to do
the shrinking but once this is done we
can move back the processing to each of
the sub modules so you can see that
adding modularity to your application
maybe you're good software practice but
it's also a good practice in terms of
the build because we're going to get
much faster over time we move as much
stuff as we can towards the the lives of
all of these modules and we can run all
of those in parallel as much as possible
once this is done in parallel we once
this is pushed back to achieve a future
module we can then resume the normal
processing and eventually we will you
know create all the necessary apks or
all the necessary artifacts to be able
to create the app bundle all right so
all of those again is in parallel now
obviously the shrinker the fact it's a
little bit of a bottleneck like I
explained earlier is usually not a
problem because not a problem for debug
build at least because usually people do
not use shrinker cut drinking during the
debug builds it's only done through for
the release builds but we really try to
limit this bottlenecks as much as we can
and Chris with explained also how we
have enhanced a lot the resource
processing with this type of
improvements another thing that we added
in 3.2
was d8 so d8 is the new JVM bytecode to
Dex file translation translator we will
eventually remove the old one which was
called DX
if you still using Dax you really need
to stop panicking because we are going
to remove it and once we removed it you
will not be able to upgrade any longer
so if you are using DX because you have
issues with d8 you must file by a bug
immediately and follow through to figure
out what's is wrong if it's with your
build or if it's with d8 itself
otherwise you're going to get stuck in
the past our eight is going to follow
more or less the same path meaning like
it's available right now to try we are
very happy with the with the results we
are getting so far so it's very stable
you should definitely try it eventually
it will become stable and you can guess
what's going to happen to the old code
shrinker to plug out eventually we will
also remove it and completely replace it
with our eight if you want more details
there is a session tomorrow that will
give you a lot more technical details
about how these two these two libraries
are implemented ok let's talk a little
bit about what's next in 3.3 so the
first time first thing I want to talk
about is lazy tasks so God has
introduced the concept of lazy tasks and
a lazy task is you should really
understand it as a task that will only
get initialized and configured if it is
on the execution tasks graph so that
means for instance if you got let's keep
it simple you've got two variants the
debug variant the release variant if you
if you're calling Istanbul debug there's
no need to crew to initialize or to
configure any of the tasks or later to
the release violent and so what's what
what we used to do unfortunately so this
was done before in this particular
example where we used to create all the
tasks we still have to do that but add
the creation time we were also
configuring them so we're ending up
configuring all the tasks for debug
variants and all that that's for release
variant even though only the debug were
eventually going to be executed with
lazy tasks the huddle is giving us the
tool to basically delay all of the
simulation initialization until it knows
that those tasks will be executed now
when I say executed it's not entirely
true because what it really means is
that it's it's going to be up to the
checked meaning it's going to look if
the task needs to be run or not by
running it's up to date checks but
potentially at least the task is on the
execution task graph and maybe executed
if it's out of date so how do you do
lazy tasks it's basically very similar
to the old to the old style instead of
doing create you could register but you
can see that now the configuration code
which is in blue here where you
initialize the input field value will
only be called if the task is on the
execution task graph now we use to
really pay a lot of attention for all of
our configuration tasks to make this
configuration block as lean as possible
because they were always executed so if
you were to do you know god--all tasks
it would always execute all of this
configuration so we try to keep it as
lean as possible with no access to disk
no access to network for instance now
it's probably a little bit more okay to
do more work in those configuration if
you really have to but you have to
remember two things first if you do real
work it will still impact your build
time because the the configuration time
is still a mono threaded event in
Caudill meaning all of the configuration
will happen one after the other so the
more you do the longer it will take and
you already know today that you know
configuration time happens all the time
it's very annoying we are really trying
to reduce it to the bare minimum but any
time is really annoying the second thing
is to not look up tasks anymore so when
you have like builder Gradle
customization a lot of people are like
you know doing project get tasks by name
or kind of stuff like that this will
actually look up the tasks and
initialize it and configure it and if
you do that it will not only do that for
the task itself but all of its
transitive dependencies as well all the
tasks its uses and all the output and
all this kind of stuff so you basically
have a good chance of initializing the
entire world instead of doing that you
should get a provider and and get a lazy
object of the task itself and use that
to register your dependency now what you
can also do if you want to have access
to the out
put of a task is used at provider and
map the output using this type of API to
get to provider so it's basically a
promise on a folder or promise of a
regular file that the tasks that may
execute will give you letter you can see
how the level of interactions you're
getting here but eventually it will give
you the idea that you can get an object
which represent the output of a task and
that object does not initialize the task
itself getting this this this provider
does not initialize the task does not
force it to run and it's really lazy and
it contains also the dependency
information means you don't have to
register yourself as a dependent of the
task producing this output folder just
holding the object itself the provider
will allow you to not only get the
object but also register your dependency
on whoever is producing it eventually
you can do a get and I will give you the
actual task at the actual object that
you can use to configure your own tasks
so here when bao is getting configured
foo gets configured and eventually all
the dependency of food will get
configured and so on and so forth so you
can say are lazy this is becoming we are
retrofitting all of our tasks to become
using providers and stuff like that so
if you use customization a lot you
really need to look into these two api's
in three three and now Chris will talk
about some of the other improvements
we've made yes another optimization to
the build pressure is coming up in 303
and is like art classes so previously
the under Gradle plugin will generate an
auto Java for every single dependency in
every sub project and then compile them
alongside your actual classes in under
Gradle plug-in 2.3 it just generates a
jar containing the class directly and
especially for those with many library
sub projects and lots of Defense's this
avoids a lot of compilation a lot of ia
for some large multi module builds and
we actually saw double digit percentage
and speed ups and when building from
clean due to this change so the our
class system in Android studio 3.3 has
been rewritten to simulate all of these
are classes in memory rather than
relying the ones on disk happily this
well as enabling this optimization of
the build it actually speeds up indexing
in Android studio as well even 40s with
all degradable plugins this does however
break some Gradle for our plugins that
depend on reading that alpha directly
including by the knife which I'm working
on fixing and it's implemented for
libraries in three dots free and we're
working on implementing it for
applications and tests you as jerome
mentioned earlier great honor how
support for incremental annotation
processing but it does need support from
the annotation processes themselves and
yeah he said that we're working to
support the most popular annotation
processes including dagger room glide
auto value and some others we're also
working to react you to data binding to
allow it to be an isolated annotation
processor speeding up your incremental
recognition even more we also want to
help you understand that bill time
impact of annotation processes so we
want to report to you like which and
visited was time spent in and how much
did they cost on the theme there are
several other areas we want to give you
better insight into your build easily
and simply so there if you're using
annotation processors it's really
critical that you have that insight
because they're often a bottleneck for
internal worlds for a lot of builds that
we see when a greater task causes you
trouble it's really helpful to know the
Gradle plugin or the script where it was
created and what triggered it to run and
we're working to make finding about more
easy we also want to help you find these
types of issues even if you're not
actively looking for them so longer term
we want under studio to flag if there is
an issue or if something changed and
regressed and will point you towards the
Gradle build scan which is a powerful
tool for getting a bit of insight into
how your build is working ok so on from
the user kind of better insights to
complete rewrites Android resource
namespacing resource namespacing is a
completely new pipeline for compiling
and linking android resources so we're
actually doing this for two reasons
firstly speed up the build and make it
easier to understand and secondly we
want a better support dynamic features
looking at think how things work now in
the existing resource pipeline there are
two namespaces the Android platform and
everything else that means that if you
have two libraries there define a
resource of the same name and the same
type the results manager has to pick one
and it's not always clear what the right
thing to do is or even that this is
happening at all this actually also
makes splitting your apk up into several
dynamic features much more difficult as
each dynamic feature is shipped
separately
where those resources come from and
where they go is really important so
with resource namespacing each library
is compiled and linked separately and
then linked together into the final apks
the r-class in applications will no
longer have final IDs and then when
you're using resources from both xml and
from java you need to be explicit about
where they came from
so each resources only listed in the
archives for the library that defined it
and an XML you need to use the namespace
of the resource to refer to it this also
means the resources no longer implicitly
override one another just because they
had the same name for cases where you
needed these overrides in the
application we rockin a new way to do
that explicitly ARS that we generate
from main space libraries will be backed
as compatible so you can have all the
benefits of namespacing yourself and but
not impose it on your consumers until
they're ready to switch ok passing on to
Isabela to tell you a bit more about the
details thank you okay now that we know
what resource namespacing is let's move
on to how to in the future namespace
your app or library you might find
yourself asking questions like where is
that resource coming from or what is the
proper syntax or how do I even they
speak my dependencies well the answer to
all these questions is we'll fix it for
you
so yes so the solution is automatic
named spacing or out on name spacing for
short
there are two main parts here first is
the automatic rewriting tool in the IDE
which will help you migrate your local
modules to be namespace and the second
one are the transforms and tasks in the
Gradle plugin that will rewrite your the
remote dependencies under the hood no
actions required here it's a example
dependency graph the blue not the blue
notes are local modules that can be
rewritten using the IDE tool the three
orange notes are not namespaced classic
remote libraries that will be
automatically rewritten by the AGP this
means all the resources classes the
manifests will be rewritten to use the
full resource space and finally the
green notes are they represent
dependencies that are already named
spaced so they will not be modified at
all let's see what types of changes we
can see after this migration takes place
in the bytecode or cotton in Java
sources you can see that now there will
be different our classes present if a
resource was defined in a different
module or a remote library you will see
the package of the our class will change
to match that package in the XML
resource references like in the values
files or in the manifest you will see
the new name space appear between the at
symbol and the type of the resource
similar to the android namespace and
finally another way resources can be
referenced is in attributes for example
in layouts here the xml namespace will
be modified to point to the correct
package instead of res auto and the
attribute will use this new namespace as
well and since we already on the topic
of resources let's talk about research
visibility so probably many of you
created an android library with a lot of
effort into declaring which resources
are public and then publish this aar
with a public txt only for consumers to
ignore it this currently is only a
Lindt warning this code compiles and
runs fine at runtime completely ignoring
the intended visibility of the resource
I'm sure many you actually ignore these
warnings as well great so to combat this
we want to introduce stricter resource
visibility so these violations will now
become build errors instead so it will
catch them early and we want to use
three levels of visibility one public
this means these resources will be
present both in a public art classes of
the consumers and the private art
classes or for that local module private
resources only present in private art
classes and last private XML only
resources they will be not present in
any art classes at all instead they will
be only you can only reference them from
Auto X other XML files within that
module this will result in smaller art
classes both compile and run time and
also resource hermit ization similar to
the class or method hermit ization
currently in Java or Kotlin so if that's
you thank you all right so as you can
see we're working on a lot of things and
many of which we hope would help with
beat speed but going back to my point
around awareness and tooling I want to
assure some of the things that you can
do today to understand your build better
and improve its performances so the
first things is to upgrade if you recall
my first graph we do improve with every
release and so if you really care about
your bill speed the best thing to do is
to upgrade to the latest stable beta
canary whichever you feel most
comfortable with down to toolings
there's a some tools out there that you
can start leveraging to better
understand your builds one that I really
like is - - scan
it's a free tool from Gradle it applauds
some of your build data into Gradle
servers and then provide a very
comprehensive dashboards around task
durations plugins dependencies and many
many more things so if you're trying to
understand what's going on with your Bo
why is it slow this is a very very
useful resource to use if sharing some
of your build data with Gradle is not
something you feel comfortable doing
there's the poor's men's version of it
which is - - profile - - profile we'll
create a local HTML file that you can
open in a browser to show some
information about your bill it's
definitely not as rich as the - - gun
but it provides some information and
remains local you can combine it with -
- info which gives you information on
why a given task right another tip which
is more of a continuous request is to
file bug we really try to tests oliver
releases on as many environment and use
cases that we can can but there's always
edge cases and different configurations
out there so please file bugs when you
encounter issues and when you do file
about please include an scan with it it
really helped us deep go deeper into the
issue and understand what's going on
last but not least if you're writing
plug-ins whether it's for you to publish
them or it's just or even just
customized a little bit your build file
here is a set of tips to follow so first
as jerome alluded to configuration is
really just to set up tasks not really
do anything else and as when as was
mentioned earlier remember if you need
to compute things for up-to-date shaykhs
checks you can always use provider and
suppliers to only run those checks if
your task is part of the active graph
for example in configuration you should
not do things like query get read a file
search for a connected device or compute
anything
configuration is really just a place to
set up tasks and it's the place to set
up old tasks because bill doesn't really
know what pass is gonna take in advance
so really try to set up all of your
tasks in the configuration step
regarding tasks make sure that each
tasks declare declare all input and
outputs even if it's non file ones and
make sure that their incremental and
cacheable if you're working with a
complex step try to split it into
multiple tasks this really helped with
the increment allottee because some
tasks could be up to date what other do
work and if you have multiple tasks they
could run in parallel so it helps with
incrementality and parallelism a third
best practice sounds obvious but I still
want to put it out there just make sure
your tasks don't write into or delete
any other task output when you rent at
Trask live I'm sorry when you write
tasks use Java and Kotlin instead of
groovy and put them in a plugin slash
build SRC file folder and last but not
least as you've heard from jerome
leverage the new worker api why we
didn't talk about this no but leverage
the new worker api i did talk about that
and stuff yeah that really helps with
proble ism alright if you didn't get
clear pictures of all of what I just
said don't worry we're working on a full
write-up covering everything that we
talked about around speed around the
findings that I shared the tooling the
best practices and more so stay tuned to
recap here's the takeaway from this
session first which we shared some
finding on speed and that we're
basically a little bit outpaced by some
of the features the plugins and all the
other things that are impacting build
speed but we're taking this very
seriously and so we're doubling down our
effort on better tooling and attribution
that you heard as well as continuing to
improve performance
we share the new features in 3d - and I
definitely encourage you to upgrade to
3.2 if you haven't already and we
mentioned some of the things that were
working for 3.3 and beyond and by the
way 3 beta is available so I encourage
you to try it it has all some of the
things that we mentioned like lazy tasks
and others and last I talked about some
of the tools that he can use - - can - -
profile today to understand your bill
and share some of the best practice if
you're writing plug-ins or customizing
your build speed that's it for today I
want to make a bad joke but unlike Biel
that we finished earlier than expected
so
[Music]